Notice that this loop counter here is not only
there to control how many times the loop should iterate.
It can actually be used inside the loop as a variable. Let's see how.
Say for example you want to change the warning message
to actually say the number of the warning it's displaying,
like Warning # 1,
Warning # 2, 3, 4, and 5.
This can be done by simply concatenating our variable i to our warning message here.
Everything else can remain the same.
Let's trace this program and see what's going on.
If we call our function raiseAlarm by passing in the value of five,
so number of warnings is equal to five.
We start by initializing i to one,
and then we compare i to the number of warnings.
If it's less than or equal to five,
which is true, so we step inside our loop.
First thing we're doing is we're printing out warning number concatenated with i.
In that case i is equal to one.
So this is going to print out Warning # 1.
We've reached the end of the loop,
so what's the first thing we do?
We increment i, making it two,
and then, once we increment i we go and do our check.
Two is less than or equal to five,
and that's true, so we step inside our loop.
Now i is equal to two,
so when we concatenate it with warning number,
we get the message Warning # 2.
Iterating so we increment i,
we do our comparison,
and then we step inside making Warning # 3,
because i is three,
and the same for four,
we do our comparison,
print it out and five print it out and then once i becomes six,
so six is no longer less than or equal to five,
so we do not step inside our loop and we just finish our function.
We can do a lot of cool stuff using the variable i,
because it keeps changing as the loop increments.
However, you have to be very careful not to change the variable i,
because it's still used to control the loop.
Let's have a look at an example.
This loop here starts with initializing i to one and it keeps
iterating as long as i is less than or equal to three and it increments i by one.
The first thing it does is it takes away one from i and it prints out i.
If we think of what this loop is doing,
it obviously loops from one to three so it goes one, two, three.
And then we're subtracting one and we're printing i.
So maybe we can think that this would print zero, one, two.
Well, let's trace it and see what we get.
First thing we do is we initialize i to one and then we
do our comparison is i less than or equal to three? Yes, it is.
So we step inside and then the first thing we do
is we change i to be equal to i minus one.
So that makes i zero,
because we subtract one from i and that was one,
and we update i to become that subtraction, which is zero.
And then we printout i,
which in our case is zero,
so the output becomes zero.
We end our loop,
we go back up here.
The first thing we do is we increment i making it
one and then we do our comparison i less than or equal to three.
Yes, it is. So we step inside our loop and we do this again.
We subtract one from i which was one making it
zero and then we step into the print line and print out zero.
We finish our loop, we go back up here,
we increment i to become one again.
And of course one is still less than or equal to three,
and that keeps on happening over and over and over.
This actually is called an infinite loop,
because this loop would never end.
It would keep repeating itself for infinity.
You have to actually stop your program and force to quit it.
Infinite loops are quite common if you're not careful enough.
So, feel free to use i as part of your program inside
the loop but always be careful not to change it to something that is not in your control.
In this case, the problem was because we were assigning a value to i,
while i was still being used as our loop counter,
and because every time we increment it and then decremented again,
I would always iterate between one and zero and it would never end,
because it would never reach three.
However, if we implement our loop this way,
then we're safe. Let's have a look at why.
The only change we did,
is we created this new variable x and when we subtract one from i,
we actually store it in x rather than update the variable i.
Let's trace this and see what happens.
i starts by one and then we check if it's less than or equal to three.
It is, so we step inside and then we update the variable x to be i minus one.
So one minus one is zero,
so x becomes zero.
And then we print out x.
So our output becomes zero.
We finish this iteration so we go back up.
We add one to i, and notice here because I hasn't
changed so we're adding one to one and it becomes two.
Two is still less than or equal to three, so it's true.
So we step inside our loop and then we update x to be i minus one.
i is two so x becomes one.
And then we print out x,
which in our case is one so we print out one.
This is the end of this iteration, we go back up,
we increment i to make it three and then we do our comparison,
and in this case it's still true,
so we step inside our loop,
we update x to become two and then we print out x here.
We go back up for increment i, making it four,
but four is no longer less than or equal to three,
so we're not going to even step into the loop,
we're not going to update x and we're not going to print out anything.
This is the end of the loop.
The reason this was safe compared to the infinite loop we had
earlier is because we were not updating the variable i.
So the lesson learned from this is that we are
allowed to use i as a variable as long as we don't update it.
Let's see another example that's also safe.
In this example, the only thing we're doing inside
the loop is we're saying print i, i times two.
Notice that we're not updating i,
were just multiplying it by two as we're printing it out.
So instead of printing out i,
were printing out twice i.
Let's trace this program and see what's happening.
The first thing is we initialize i to be one,
and then we compare it if it's less than or equal to three,
which is true, so we step inside,
we printout i times two,
which is two because i is one.
We reach the end of the iteration,
we increment i to become two.
The reason that this is okay is because i hasn't changed,
so when we reached our increment,
it was still one so it jumps up to two as normal.
And then we do our comparison,
i is less than or equal to three. Yes, it is.
So we step inside.
We print i times two.
i is two, so the output would be four.
And then we go back up,
we increment i to become three,
three is still less than or equal to three,
so we step inside and we print out three times two which is six.
We increment i which makes it four,
but four is no longer less than or equal to three,
so that's false and we don't print anything.
Once that condition becomes false,
we do not step into the loop and we just exit. So there you go.
It's really handy when we use the variable i
or whatever the loop counter is called inside our loop.
Remember that you could also do this with while loops of course,
just be very careful not to change it.
Let's have a look at how we can actually use loops to calculate stuff for us.